dre demandé un peu aux professeurs je
suis présente ses professeurs les cartes
dans cette émission du 1er avril vous
avez vous pensé à inviter sérieux qui
est bien peu sort seront alors je vous
laisse vous entretenir avec lui thierry
parce que je ne sais pas de quoi vous
voulez parler justement je parlais de
des problèmes de l'hérédité et j'ai vu
une revue scientifique qui vient de
sortir aujourd'hui je crois à qui rit et
où il y a
il y a enfin dire comment on pourrait y
arriver on parle d'insémination
artificielle c'est ça oui oui tout le
monde a lu dans la presse
c'est fou américain qui essaient de
concevoir des enfants nobel par
insémination artificielle
or chacun sait que toute société humaine
digne de ce nom a pour base inébranlable
la bêtise et la méchanceté
il fallait donc que nous réagissions
nous hara kiri journal bête et méchant
nous avons donc trouvé à malley talons
débordant de bêtises de méchanceté c'est
coluche qui nous après prodigués sont
sans pression précieux liquide
aggoun s'engage sur un terrain mais il
aurait voulu dans chacun des treize ans
d'un père à côté avec l'interdiction
vient peut-être son mot à dire on verra
après on voulait faire dans chaque
numéro de hara kiri de ce mois ci il y à
un sachet contenant de l'authentic
sperme de coluche alors c'est sûrement
de moi serait que son imprésario mais on
a prélevé 35 ans cette charmante
demoiselle qui hélas a été inséminée
artificiellement par à moi même il y a
une semaine
elle est donc enceinte de coluche débit
jours alors je veux rassurer tout l'été
toutes les téléspectatrices que ça
intéresse elle va très bien c'est
pourquoi je la porte est là pour en
apporter la preuve
alors si dans neuf fois où vous pouvez
m'a vite et on pourra même faire
l'accouchement télévisés et on verra le
petit monstre vous avez encore une
question à poser aux professeurs rien
moi j'aimerais bien avoir le point de
vue quand même du père à ce point de vue
là je trouve que
dans une émission de grande écoute à une
heure aussi est vraiment beaucoup d'un
enfant elle écoute je trouve que c'est
un propos qui est très déplacé je suis
très choqué oui mais moi je suis très
chaud qui fit est assis à côté d'un père
allait sur qui tous les deux l'épreuve
de choc
[Musique]